vous avez écrit un livre qui s'appelait
problème du Nouveau Roman et maintenant
c'est nouveau problème du roman c'est
quoi c'est un jeu de mot entre les deux
ou apparemment oui mais qu'est-ce qu'il
y a il y a vraiment des nouveaux
problèmes dans le roman euh oui quand
c'est un roman
nouveau ah alors vous voulez dire par là
il y a pas de problème pour tous les
romans qu'on a présenté là et bien c'est
ce que il me semble les écrivains ont
essayer de montrer c'est-à-dire qu'il
n'y avait pas de problème littéraire
mais qu'il y avait la vie toute crue
alors ils ont le droit de de le n'est-ce
pas tout à fait et d'écrire comme ils le
veulent et de dire ce qu'ils veulent
mais effectivement il y a une autre
sorte de littérature qui se présente de
façon disons un peu moins naïve dans
dans ce qu'elle est non pas que les gens
qui soient là soi naïfs mais il y a une
présentation naïve de leur livre qui est
de raconter les histoires comme si de
rien nétait il me semble que toute une
série de romans dans l'après-guerre
disons sont devenus problématiques pour
les lecteurs puisque les lecteurs ont eu
quelquefois et surtout les critiques
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus que les
lecteurs certains critiques ont eu du
mal à les lire donc le fait qu'il y ait
problème une sit oui par exemple entre
autres le nouveau roman mais je croyais
que le nouveau roman était mort j'entend
ou moi vous entende vous entendez dire
ça partout et je dirais moi que je
l'entends depuis toujours c'est-à-dire
depuis qu'on a parlé de nouveau roman on
a dit qu'il était mort et chaque année
on disait qu'il était mort cette année
on dit peut-être encore qu'il est mort
on le dira peut-être encore dans 10 ans
c'est-à-dire que on a du mal à le tuer
mais dans le au début de votre livre
vous faites une distinction non pas
entre le roman et le nouveau roman mais
vous entre le roman et le rétrrooman
oui c'est-à-dire que à une certaine
époque ces livres nouveau qui gênait un
petit peu la critique on les a appelé le
nouveau roman par opposition au roman
qui était le roman dont on avait
l'habitude et c'est une distinction qui
a fonctionné pendant quelques années
alors aujourd'hui ce qui est peut-être
possible de voir c'est que ces livres
d'une sorte un petit peu nouvelle sont
devenus de plus en plus nombreux et il
n'y a pas de raison de ne pas penser
qu'il ne soit pas le la transformation
du roman en cours donc on peut appeler
ça le roman et à ce moment-là le roman
euh disons traditionnel on pourrait
aussi bien l'appeler le rétroroman
c'estàd
enverserot opinion tous les romans que
nous avons présenté là est-ce qu'ils
appartiennent tous au
rétroman JEE la question aè vous parle
je je ne vois pas grand intérêt à à
donner des des médailles euh des
récompenses ou des châtiments d'ailleurs
le châtiment est l'inverse d'une
récompense et vic-versa aux personnes
qui sont là je ne suis pas là pour je ne
suis pas là pour placer des étiquettes
sur des travaux je suis là pour essayer
de comment vous placez plein
d'étiquettes là de travaux non non non
jamais d'étiquettes de cet ordre
j'essaie de comprendre des
fonctionnements des textes et non pas de
dire un tel c'est du rétrrooman un tel
c'est du roman euh ça n'est pas pas très
intéressant pour le public les gens
veulent savoir peut-être certaines gens
du moins veulent savoir comment
fonctionn certains textes et c'est ce
que je leur explique mettre des
étiquettes alors non à partir de à
partir de de Prous de flauert Rob
Grillet Claude Simon et de et de
vous-même oui et qu'est-ce que vous
faites donc alors qu'est-ce que vous
prenez ces texes et qu'est-ce que vous
en faites B je pense que vous l'avez vu
un petit peu oui mais expli oui et bien
je considère ces textes en tant que
texte c'està-dire ça n'est pas seulement
des histoires qui sont raconter plus ou
moins intéressante plus ou moins facile
à comprendre mais c'est aussi des mots
qui sont placés sur une page et sur une
série de pages et qui entretiennent des
relations par exemple si on ouvre la
première page de la recherche du temps
perdu et puis si on va chercher dans le
dernier volume la dernière page et si on
les compare on s'aperçoit qu'il y a des
ressemblances de mots extraordinaires
par exemple tout le monde connaît la
première phrase de la recherche du temps
perdu longtemps je me suis couché de
bonheur et la dernière avec le dernier
mot c'est dans le temps c'est-à-dire que
vous avez le même mot au début et à la
fin ça n'est pas un hasard à ce
moment-là on peut s'amuser à regarder
les autres mots on s'aperçoit qu'on a
dans la première phrase longtemps temps
et temps dans dans des phrases
différentes et dans la dernière on a
l'inverse on a longtemps longtemps et
temps alors évidemment si on s'en tient
là ce sont de simples ressemblant formel
mais on peut les considérer comme des
poteosindicateurs et à la suite de cela
on se met à regarder plus
particulièrement ce début et cette fin à
3000 pages d'écart n'est-ce pas mais
pour l'écrivain il avait l'une et
l'autre à côté quand il a écrit pour le
lecteur elles sont à 3000 pages pour lui
elles étaient l'une à côté de l'autre et
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a des
ressemblances véritablement
extraordinaire entre ces deux pages et
toute la recherche du temps perdu
commence à à à se boucler sur 3000 page
on revient alors au début et on relit
tout d'une façon différente d'une
lecture naïve initial voilà un des des
petits exemples qui montre ce que c'est
qu'un texte en dehors même de l'histoire
qu'il raconte mais c'est un ouvrage très
savant il y a un chapitre qui qui
s'intitule l'orisis inéluctable ou
dispositif
osiriaque il y a des graphiques il y a
des non mais le mot le mot Osiris vous
semble savant non non pas non non je
écoutez quand on fait une étude sur là
je crois que c'est le roman c'est vous
parlez de claud Simon il me semble bon
je quand on voit le dispositif auiriac
dans chapitre je dire bon bien ça va sur
quand je veux dire ça vous semble un mot
difficile auirac non c'est l'ensemble
qui me paraî le dispositif qui me paraît
pas pas très comme ça j dessus comme ça
surtout c'est accompagn de
graphi
question pasileis poser une question
sérieuse jeis une question série est-ce
que qu'est-ce que je veux dire que
est-ce que véritablement notre
lecture après lecture de votre livre
est-ce que notre lecture des auteurs
dont vous parlez va
changer c'est pour ça que je voulais
faire une remarque DEP tout àheure je
crois qu'elle va changer mais à
condition de m'avoir lu malgré tout et
de ne pas être arrêté par le simple mot
dispositif osiren qu' très surprenant en
ce qui me concerne enc je parle de moi
je suis désolé le quand le l'ombre
miroir d'ici dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure apparu il y a 20 ans aux
Éditions de Minuit les les traducteurs
hollandais critiques hollandais ont dit
c'était la réussite du nouveau
roman du mien et
jeevis c'est très rigolo parce que je
l'avais fait en effet d'une façon
mathématique n'est-ce pas et ça se lit
aujourd'hui les critiques que j'ai lu ça
se lit comme tout à fait
différemment c'est c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure que il y avait
deux possibilités de lecture pour pour
vos texte en particulier ou enfin je
parle de moi parce que je je suis au
courant de ce ou c'est ça voilà alors
c'est tout le même C vous cro que c'est
important de démonter le truc tout
illusionniste à un truc ça nche SP il y
a deux sortes de gens oui il y a des
gens qui vont euh voir l'illusionistes
et qui veulent simplement subir
l'illusion c'est leur droit bien entendu
pu ne sont pas d pour l'utant il faut
pas les prendre pour des imbéciles ils
savent très bien que si vo la femme si
c'est pas vra femme ils sont ravis de
cette illusion d' d'accord mais il y en
a d'autres aussi qui trouvent cela
extrêmement savoureux et qui trouvent
aussi du plaisir à savoir comment c'est
fait pourquoi la différence c'est que si
l'on veut soi-même faire des tours et
bien on est intéressé par la façon dont
les autres le font alors le fait de
s'intéresser au texte et de démonter les
textes comme je le fais euh cela peut
donner envie d'écrire à des gens qui
croient que c'est un mystère d'écrire
n'est-ce pas si l'on en parle jamais si
l'on raconte simplement les histoires ou
les événements émouvants que l'on a vécu
euh bon c'est très bien mais en même
temps les gens se disent ah mais moi
aussi j'ai eu des histoiresmouvantes
mais mais comment ils font pour écrire
vous avez le dire qu'il y a des
illusionnistes qui n'auraient pas de
truc il seraient des faux illusionnistes
et des vrais illusionnistes qui aurait
le truc du nouveau roman c'est ça qui
est un peu étrange a que des
illusionnistesis il n'y a que des
illusionnistes mais le problème est
peut-être de démonter les trucs pour
donner envie aux autres d'écrire au
ricardo est un peu le majac de
la
oui mais j'espère que mon livre aura
autant de succès que les
opérationtre non c'était une émission
intéressante de voir comment on fait le
truc c'est je reconnais